you've authored
many super interesting books uh lots of
which have been turned into
feature movies like the movie 21
um the social network
and didn't you write for the x-files at
one point
yeah so early early early in my career
um i worked for the x-files i wrote a
book for them
so it was like a standalone thriller
starring mulder and scully
um so this was a long time ago but yeah
i started off my career writing
techno thrillers um medical thrillers
you know
i wanted to be michael crichton that was
kind of my goal um
and uh nobody read those so they didn't
do very well
um and it wasn't until i started writing
non-fiction that my career kind of took
off
um but uh but yeah the x-files is one of
the first things that i worked for yeah
awesome so did you ever work with vince
scale again um i mean
phone wise you know they were up in
vancouver shooting the show so i went up
there
once um but i wasn't you know
on set or anything like that for
anything you get
pitched a lot of stories i assume
every day every week from different
people um
out of all like the different stories
and ideas that get
thrown across your desk all the time how
do you choose which ones to pursue
yeah i mean it's tricky so basically
ever since i wrote bringing down the
house about the mit blackjack team
and that book kind of exploded among
college kids and so
after that book came out and then the
movie came out
people would just email me or send
things to my twitter i would get pitched
two stories a week um and usually
you know it's somebody in prison trying
to trying to make their case or it's
some story that
isn't gonna be you know it's something
personal someone wrong them or something
like that
so most of the stories you just know
aren't going to be the right story
but for me i'm always looking for
something that's like big enough
that everyone in the world will
recognize it in like one sentence
but not already so well known that
you've already seen it a million times
and so it's that tricky kind of you know
sweet spot
between something you don't really have
to explain um
to something that you don't already know
um and it also has to be
a movie like i won't write a project or
even start a book
if i don't think it can be a major movie
and in fact
for the past i would say 15 books i've
sold the movie
before i've sold the book so i write a
proposal
sell the movie rights and then sell the
book rights and write the book
so i won't even go into it if i don't
think there's something big enough to be
a big hollywood movie
wow and was the first book that you
wrote or the first book that you
authored that turned into a movie was it
the movie 21 um you know i had a tv
movie way back in my
my crappy techno thriller days i wrote a
book called reaper
which was about a computer virus that
makes the jump to the biological world
and people start getting sick from their
tvs and from their phones um
yeah i wrote that a long time ago and
that was made into a tbs's premiere
movie back in 2000 i think it was start
antonio sabato jr and robert wagner
i think you can find it somewhere on
ebay but um
my first feature film was 21 um
which was bringing down the house um and
uh came out
i think the movie was like 2007 the book
was 2002.
yeah so could you give me sort of the
backstory on that how that all came
about and how you
got into that story or how that story
came across your
path yeah so i was writing you know
thrillers i was trying to be a
a thriller writer um and uh they weren't
going well nobody was reading i had
gotten myself hugely into debt
um uh hugely into debt like million and
a half dollars in debt
i had irs agents calling me i was like
you know
i was in a messy situation i had
something like
seventy thousand dollars in credit card
debt and and i basically had a stack of
business school applications that i was
filling in because i was thinking
there's only
one way i'm ever going to get out of
this hole i've dug and that's to go to
business school and go to wall street
um get some more student loans that was
it i was in a troubled situation
um and then there was this group of mit
college kids
um i was introduced to them by the girl
on the team
who was a friend of mine from college i
went to harvard down the street
and they used to hang out in this local
bar called crossroads
um in boston uh and uh i would go in
there and hang out with these mit kids
and they were telling me these crazy
stories the main character's name was
jeff ma
in real life um and jeff would tell me
these amazing stories about him and his
buddies going to vegas every weekend
and using math to beat the game of
blackjack
and i went to his house and he had like
a quarter million dollars and 100
bills just jammed in his laundry and i
was like this is really cool
i got to start going to vegas and so i
started going to vegas with them
um and uh and i thought this was better
than all the crap i've been writing
um so i wrote a i wrote it up i i
sent it to my agent and he said well
nobody really cares about
cards because this was right before
chris moneymaker won the world series of
poker so
cards in vegas were not yet hot this was
like 2000
or even the late 90s when i was started
writing it and uh and so
i sold the book for a tiny amount of
money um
and uh and it exploded i mean when it
came out it was just
a huge book it was on the new york times
list for 63 weeks and uh
it was um just one of those things that
life-changing moments
and uh and around the same time i had
written
an article for wired magazine about this
mit blackjack team
and kevin spacey read it and back then
getting a phone call from kevin spacey
was like a good thing
um and so you know kevin kevin called on
the phone
um and i remember getting the phone call
and i didn't really believe it was kevin
spacey
yeah you know like i ended up hanging up
on him i thought it was a prank phone
call
um but it really was spacey and he
invited me out to la and said i want to
make this into a movie
um and that became the movie 21 and so
it was kind of this
you know life-changing story and
suddenly i was a nonfiction writer um
not really by choice
uh but that was the book that that did
well and suddenly you know everyone
started pitching me stories and that's
where my career really started
so he didn't have any ulterior motives
when he flew you out to l.a right
you know kevin uh kevin was always great
with me i don't know why
it wasn't his type kevin was always
wonderful he was a
you know a phenomenal actor um oh yeah
you know it was odd kevin's odd i mean
you you know
you knew stuff was going on i mean you
thought you didn't know what was really
going on
but you you knew he was living you know
a different lifestyle than maybe
you might guess but um but no i never
really you know
uh saw anything that was that was you
know what what came
later um at the time he really was
uh helpful he set up this movie um said
he wanted a star in it and
that's pretty much the only way to get a
movie made you know is to have a major
actor
or a director or someone at an a level
involved in it
um and it took years though it took five
years to get that movie made it wasn't
like an overnight kind of situation
um but the book was on the list for a
couple of years which was amazing
um and uh and started off my career in a
really great way
yeah that's interesting he called so he
called you directly
yeah so his assistant at the time was a
guy named dana brunetti
dana actually is now a very big producer
and uh
you know we worked together on a lot of
projects and then he went on and helped
me do the social network and then he did
50 shades of gray and made a pile of
money and now
it's like a prepper living in northern
california but dana um dana was his
assistant and basically found my phone
number
and just called with kevin on the line
um
and said you know we want to we want to
make this project and uh
you know it was a crazy time in my life
i was massively in debt i had no money
i flew out to la and met with them and
uh i remember their pitch
you know they were they took me to the
playboy mansion
i landed and basically they drove me
straight to the playboy mansion
um to to woo me into signing the deal
with them
so uh so it was a kind of a wild sort of
hollywood moment and
and um at the time they i was in mass
you know i had no money and
kevin and dana said we want to make a
movie and i said great how much
are you gonna pay me and they said
nothing and i was like what do you mean
they're like we're gonna
we're not gonna give you anything um but
you know we'll make this movie
and around the same time another group
of producers
offered me 750 000 for the rights
and so i went back to kevin and dana and
said these other people are offering me
three quarters of a million dollars i'm
majorly in debt
you have to give me something and dana
said to me
if i gave you a big check right now what
would you do with it and i said well you
know i'd probably
spend it because that's what i i was
living this crazy lifestyle i was
blowing through all my money that's just
the way i was living
so he said we're going to give you
something better you can
use our name you can use kevin's name
you can go out there and promote the
book
and we're definitely going to make this
movie and it's going to be worth way
more in the long run
and so i ended up turning down the
three-quarters of a million dollars and
taking
zero to make the movie with kevin and uh
and it ended up being the right choice
um because i i booked the today show
went on the today show and talked about
it and
the book just skyrocketed and everything
kind of worked out and the movie got
made
so who knows what would have happened if
i had gone the other route but uh but it
was a it was one of those sort of wild
hollywood moments
wow that is super interesting what a
weird moment
going straight to the playboy mansion
with kevin spacey
you know it's funny now that sounds very
different than it did then
yeah right back then it was you know
they said i was a kid living in boston
you know it was
it was a long time ago and you walk in
there and it's like wow
at the time it was the greatest place to
be in the world and
it was amazing and wild um and it was it
was neat i've always sort of looked at
hollywood as this place that i
can jump in and out of i never wanted to
live in la i never wanted to be
in hollywood but i love the idea of
being a boston guy living in boston and
being able to sort of
go there when i need to for a couple
days and then and then get back out
yeah i'm with you on that hollywood's a
weird place i'm not a fan
of that area for more than two
24 hours to 48 hours i want to get out
just like vegas the best days when you
get there
or the best two days the day you get
there the day you leave
i